I saw you tweet this recently and it
really,
uh,
shook me a little bit.
I was shocked.
I was shocked to see this.
I like this one a lot.
I'll introduce this.
So,
so you said those who consider
themselves my enemies had been posting
these all around my home neighborhood
and it says here,
Community Safety Bulletin,
Jordan Pearson,
a local man teaching at the University
of Toronto has been championing against
the human rights of women,
people of color,
Muslims and l,
G,
b t people for over a year.
Peterson has opened association with Neo
Nazis and the outright even being
referred to as a Nazi philosopher by the
leader of the new constitution party of
Canada due to pressure from Jordan
Peterson's alright.
Fan Base,
the University of Toronto has not taken
any action to fire him or disavow his
attacks on minority groups.
Look,
this is awful.
I mean that's something where there's a
bunch of things about it that I really,
that,
that are really creative.
Let's say the first is they posted it in
my neighborhood which is really nasty
and it's really underhanded.
And,
and,
and like thoughtfully.
So,
you know,
there's a double message there,
it's like we know where you are,
we know where your family is and we're
perfectly willing to,
um,
make that known and to hypothetically
embarrass you in front of your neighbors
and the community safety bulletin,
that's really a little stroke of genius,
you know,
because people are going to watch that.
And then one of the most underhanded
things they did,
they'll,
which,
which you can't really tell by looking
at the poster because I look kind of
angry there and it looks like exactly.
I'm going to choose something off there.
And um,
but what's really interesting about that
is that that picture was taken at a
rally that I spoke out in favor of free
speech,
of course,
that I was invited to speak at.
And during the rally,
the same kind of activist who put up
this poster,
took the mic and shut off the PA system
and blasted everyone with white noise.
So in order to be heard,
I had to raise my voice a lot.
And so they took a picture.
So really here I am,
they baby to essentially made it
impossible for me to speak unless I
spoke very loudly and so that's what I'm
doing here.
So they actually took a picture of me
reacting appropriately in the situation
to provocation from them to make me look
like,
well,
who knows?
Like,
like,
well,
like an angry,
like a,
like an angry guy,
or you just want to,
you want to round up some minorities.
I look of it.
Yep.
This is some impressive propaganda,
mean genius.
You're right.
It is.
It's impressive.
It's disturbing that people are,
can be so consciously manipulative.